welcome back well brexit has that this
week being delayed by another six months
and our next guest is today urging the
prime minister that she should now be
prepared to leave the EU without a deal
we're joined now by the former
Conservative Party leader in Duncan
Smith thank you very much for being on
the show so what's your reaction n-2
this delay well I think it was very
interesting I haven't seen a lot of
stuff from constituents coming in from
the beginning but it was on the 29th
when we didn't leave that's when this
has all gone wrong up until then people
were prepared to give tourism a the
benefit of the doubt but they knew that
she had said she would leave on the 29th
of March and the big problem was as soon
as we didn't leave you can see all the
poll ratings start to crash and it's
wholly linked to the fact that leave all
remained they were expecting us to go
when we didn't go it look like a
complete breach with the pledge that we
had made and that's a disaster for a
political party and there's no question
that polling at the moment I think it's
very voluble very flexible but it's um
it's where it is now and I suspect it's
about right and the Sunday Telegraph
leading on poll of polls that they've
done so the Labour Party would be the
largest party if there was a general
election and Jeremy called win in number
10 I mean do you think that is the case
well you know this is three or four
years out from the next election and
there's a lot to go so I don't I just
cannot conceive the British public with
jeremy corbyn's background and a party
that was marred in some charges of
anti-semitism and really ghastly
misogyny and various other problems that
they've got going on a man who backs the
venezuela dictator who's been murdering
his own people all of these things will
come home to roost but he stands charged
with supporting Maduro when the rest of
the world says madeira must go in
Venezuela but you know it's kind of
Marxism and and my point about this is
whether that people like it or they
don't like it none of that will be on
display because it's all about brexit at
the moment it's all about whether the
Conservatives have delivered on their
ability to leave the European Union and
we really have to get out and we simply
cannot fight the euro elections I gather
dozens
conservative Association members are now
written a letter to the Prime Minister
saying they are not prepared to fight
euro elections it would be an utter
disaster for us and a disaster for the
country I mean what what are you going
to say on the doorstep vote for me and
I'll be gone in three months
it doesn't make any sense well you know
I always campaigned for conservative
candidates but I absolutely do not want
to campaign on the euro election ticket
which would be almost impossible to
justify and I think the public will ask
why are we going to spend 109
million-plus and add another billion a
month to that by being full members of
the EU when we could have left and we
should leave so I think the date isn't
October at all the date is the key
moment in May when we have to put up
electoral officers if we don't put those
up then we're leaving before the end of
June according to polling today your
seat is one of the ones that's high risk
well I you know I have a seat that is
marginal like a lot of colleagues do and
we're fighting very hard we haven't seen
a massive change in that I have to tell
you but notwithstanding their and I
think it's important for us to recognize
across the board the idea of a
government run by Jeremy Corbyn with all
those Marxist policies it's just going
to be disaster for the United Kingdom
but you think yes it would be no I think
I'll hold my seat because I believe I've
been clear and straight with my
electorate since the day I was elected
and they know my views on this and they
know my views on a whole range of other
issues which I've been very clear about
social justice set up the ket the centre
for social justice and very keen to see
the worst off improve their lives in the
best way possible and that's lots of
changes needed to our policy process at
the moment but the reality is you know
here we have this irony that the the
economy has a has a current account
surplus we have the lowest unemployment
the highest employment the lowest youth
unemployment literally for decades the
economy is now seen as a very very good
investment by external people who are
holding back because of brexit with all
of those and with the deficit down to 1%
we should be romping home in the polls
why are we not because the one thing the
public at the moment fears is that we
haven't delivered on our word which was
to leave on March the 29th now we keep
extending with extension I've always
said it's political death we have to
make a decision either there
to modify their agreement which is a
biggest problem as the backstop you know
this I went the other day I think there
is some scope for some further
discussions about alternative
arrangements why because the EU
themselves have now said that no matter
what there will not be a hard border on
the border nor none and they'll have
alternative arrangements well if they're
going to do that for No Deal their
threat that there would be borders hard
borders and or denial is gone that means
now there is scope to say well if you
are going to do that and we put four
proposals months ago to them about how
they would do it using existing customs
techniques then you can do it when you
have the deal that would end the whole
problem about the max so you went to
meet with Michele Barney this week did
you he was completing the brakes at
negotiations for the EU are you
seriously saying that he told you the
withdrawal agreement would be up for
renegotiation no no I'm not I'm not
going to get into this no what we
actually discussed because there are
still some scope I think but the key bit
that I think about both sides now
grudgingly accept is that the backstop
does not work it doesn't deliver what
you want it's impossible to run
practically it doesn't work and it
literally would cut Northern Ireland
away from the United Kingdon twork it
simply physically practically does not
work I know because you can't apply it
you know under the existing backstop
proposals the whole of the UK would have
to be doing some 250 million wet stamp
pieces of paper at the borders
these are plucked from the Turkish
agreement and dumped into this agreement
at the last moment it doesn't work and
they know it so they're working on this
as much as we are so my point is let's
be honest with each other
that's not wait to get this done let's
do this now and we can actually produce
alternative arrangements that mean that
Northern Ireland is no longer under
threat to be left out of the UK and we
would then be able to have an agreement
which actually works that's a
possibility as a very strong possibility
right now but we've got to get on with
it another possibility is staying in are
you worried that we might actually end
up never leave it I believe we have to
leave I believe we will leave both
parties were elected on manifestos that
said they were leaving leaving the
custom
in single market the problem has been
that inside Parliament it's stuffed full
of people who have never accepted the
result the problem is really being and
in a sense mrs. Mae made this clear it's
about those in Parliament who are doing
their level best and some of them in my
party to actually frustrate and stop
brexit including some people who support
breaks that who refuse to vote well the
real problem has been that there is this
concern that what we do is we allow a
foreign power to interfere in the United
Kingdom and carve one section of the
United Kingdom out what they call UK ni
which would be in a completely separate
world from that of the UK with borders
between the UK and Northern Ireland it's
intolerable I mean you know nobody voted
for that we voted to leave clean as a
United Kingdom and I think we simply
have to do that and I really urge the
prime minister to be very clear with
them we're not fighting the European
election any idea of doing that is
disaster if we make that clear today and
say we are going to leave Deal or No
Deal
before the euro elections now I think
the public will start to snap back and
say okay these people mean business and
when we do it that's the moment when
we'll end all of the nonsense from these
other peripheral parties like you kept
in the brexit party and the Tiggers I
don't I was super don't worry she's like
the studio no and just when we've got
you you've called on Tories are made to
set a date for her departure when do you
think that takes you've been well I know
that the Prime Minister has already said
she's going she said she would go as and
when the agreement was ratified which
was looking at around about May June I
think those dates still stand I think
that the Prime Minister has to do is aim
everything now towards debauchery before
the euros which would then allow her to
step away having done what she said she
would do get the UK out of the European
Union one way or the other
and then we can have another leadership
election and pick a new leader which is
the way that it has to be she's accepted
and agreed that but I think that now
needs to be set down as I say there are
lots and lots of chairmen out there who
do not want to fight the European
elections and lots who are fighting the
May elections right now who are really
upset and concerned that they're going
to have a backlash in what is
important local it could be a grassroots
revolts if you like well there already
is
to be quite frank people don't want to
fight the euro elections they want to
get on with the mayor elections and they
want to do it in the sense that they can
say to the public we promised you we
would leave we are and have left so we
will leave you know before the euro
elections take place that is the key
position to be and by the way I have
real concern with some of my colleagues
going out lording Jeremy Corbyn and
saying somehow you know we agree with
quite a lot or we you know it in all of
this we used to say that he's not fit
for government my view is he's not fit
for government and nor his policies
which would wreck the economy we need to
be very clear that in the course of this
we don't end up letting Jeremy Corbyn
dictate to us that we stay on a customs
union or we have some kind of second
referendum or for that matter we are
aligned with the European single market
all of that given to us by Jeremy
coordinate is a recipe for disaster okay
sounds like you're ready to fight that
election certainly indigent Smith thank
you very much for coming on the program
this movie